my aim when I'm cooking at home during
the Christmas holidays is to make dishes
with a minimum fuss that still deliver
the wow factor
my next recipe for panna cotta takes all
the right boxes it's easy to make and
has a silky smooth texture that makes it
one of the world's sexiest desserts
first add 250 milliliters of cream to a
pan then pour in 50 mL of milk and add
50 grams of caster sugar get the sugar
in early because it stops the milk and
cream from boiling over
give that a little stir bring that Out
to the Ball
panna cotta which means cooked cream in
Italian can be flavored with anything
from vanilla to Coffee to Chocolate I'm
giving mine a grown-up kick with a
splash of rum in
once the cream has come to the boil take
it off the heat and add a couple leaves
of gelatin that have been soaked in cold
water and squeezed dry then whisk them
in
the gelatine
sets the cooked cream
so we want that really nice sort of
blancmange texture rich
silky and Incredibly smooth
once the gelatine has dissolved pour the
panna cotta straight into servant
glasses traditionally it's set in molds
then turned out onto a plate but I'm
keeping mine simple
leave a little space on top for the
glaze
now
set them into the fridge
[Music]
beautiful
next the pomegranate glaze
add some caster sugar to the pan
and pour in pomegranate juice then
simply bring it to the boil and reduce
it down to the consistency of a sticky
syrup
[Music]
in Iran where pomegranates originated
they use this Sweet Sticky syrup to
flavor chicken and game birds are
beautiful
Rich sticky glaze pour that into a jar
leave that to cool down
take the panna cotta from the fridge
they set beautifully and they're not too
firm just
slightly bouncy a little bit springy on
top carefully pour the cooled
pomegranate glaze over
rolling around a little bit just to fill
those edges finally take a bar of
chocolate that's been chilled in the
freezer so it's easier to use and scrape
off thin shards almost like sort of
chocolate Gold Leaf and sprinkle it on
top
[Music]
another Golden Rule at Christmas is
don't do all the work yourself delegate
at home I'm raising my own little
Brigade of Sous chefs who are always
willing to help with any recipe that
involves chocolate and the possibility
of licking the mixing spoon
another thing I always do the day before
Christmas is knock up a batch of mint
chocolate truffles their child's play to
make and have a wonderful fresh mint
flavor the perfect after dinner
chocolates
right Megan Jack I need some help
yeah chocolate mint truffles first
things first yeah
what we need to do is get this block of
dark chocolate and just break up into
small pieces okay magnets for you Jack
that's for you mate where do you get
that time from
right mint chocolate
truffles the secret here
is getting that mint flavor into the
chocolate so look
best thing to do get a little bunch of
mint
lightly bruise it
you can flavor the truffles with
whatever takes your fancy from fresh
chili which gives it a surprisingly
delicious kick to Orange dust to a
splash of Brandy right double cream
and single cream in
the cream makes the truffles wonderfully
soft luscious and Rich nice next add a
generous pour of Honey which helps to
sweeten the dark chocolate now bring
that to the boil now the secret is we
pour that on top of the chocolate okay
so at least we've got two minutes to get
this done quick that's why I need some
help
Dad yes can't you beat this up with a
rolling pin it's a very good idea oh
would it be too small nope it's a very
good idea because what we can't afford
to do is for the cream to reduce and the
cream reduces then the consistency of
the Truffle becomes too hard but it's a
very good idea Jack you know that
now generally with that
I've got your boyfriend a present no oh
yeah just ask it all right just asking
them
what
your big sis has got more than one
boyfriend I haven't got one
girlfriend Jack what's her name
Emma what have you bought Emma for
Christmas
don't tell me where is she Dad yeah
Daddy's restaurant next add 130 grams of
softened butter to give the truffles a
glorious richness and Sheen break it up
into small little bits
yeah nice good once the cream and milk
have come to the boil yeah it's really
nice you can really smell the mint
strain over the broken chocolate
that was delicious push that mint flavor
through there so we just come out yeah
so we just come out okay
dissolving and that honey has given it a
really nice glaze sweetness as well
because it's bitter chocolate that's
right dark chocolate and then the butter
starts to give the chocolate a really
nice shine
so the more will actually happen it
happens
that look at that oh peaceful like that
do you wanna let the spoon put your
tongue out
right
and pour the chocolate into a container
and chill in the fridge for about an
hour to firm up Jack I don't want any
fingers in there top shelf you can see
Let It Go nice and firm as the travel
mixture sets prepare the coating so I
have one for the adults in cocoa powder
yeah
and one with flakes yeah that's a
surprise surprise so wait put your hands
down put your hands down so look we just
go like that and twist the flake
on to the plate
you can coat the truffles in anything
you like finely chop pistachios or
almonds work really well with the mint
or to give them a bit of crunch plain
brown sugar
[Music]
once the Truffle mixture has set it's
time to roll out the chocolates
[Music]
right okay I'm gonna show you one first
yes so hands really nicely cold now the
secret is in there
manipulate it first like that and then
look roll and then quickly bang look
nothing on my hands shake off excess and
then just on beautiful
now in there
and let's go come on Jack dear hello
when you're ready
it'll be New Year's Eve by the time we
get one done it's time try and drop it
on there rather than place on there
sure
the nice thing about making them by hand
they're not all the exact same size yeah
handmade chocolate mint truffles Jack
the secret is a truffle is a one bite
Wonder not a golf ball how do you hurry
up because the ganache starts melting
we're in trouble I thought you said
there wasn't gonna be any chocolate on
your hand
s slow me your hands
all right let me help you
not so not so big around like that like
that
yeah and then like that in straight in
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
when the truffles are coated and the
kids are cleaned up decorate them with
sprigs of mint
so it looks nice and
flake
[Music]
are you going how many taste the mint
you can really taste them and can you
then priza travels away from the kids
and pop in the fridge ready for
Christmas day another job done
[Music]
every year when I was growing up my mum
made a traditional Christmas pudding now
I'm getting her back in the kitchen to
help me cook my updated version a modern
light steamed pudding with whiskey cream
it's super simple to make and
deliciously delicate to eat and it can
be flammed at the table so you don't
miss out on all that drama
all right mum welcome to a proper
kitchen now
today we're not going to burn anything
we're going to make a really nice
fragrance steamed yeah
sponge pudding why are you looking for
Christmas yes
why we never get to eat Christmas
pudding it's always a little bit too
full so I want to make something a
little bit lighter I didn't like to
stick to tradition and Christmas would
you mind if I just try something a
little bit different
first mum greats the zest of an orange
into a lightly buttered pudding Basin
whilst I get on with a sponge mix add
210 grams of butter and 210 grams of
light brown sugar to the mixer and beets
do you think you always good with trust
me
mum I know it's my kitchen but there's
only one way and that is my way no don't
be cheeky now
then pour a few tablespoons of maple
syrup into the pudding Basin and put in
three bay leaves Bailey's on
extraordinary versatile
[Music]
herbs they're Bittersweet spicy taste
Works brilliantly in everything from
meat stews marinades and fish dishes to
Sweet custards and rice puddings to
finish the sponge mix beat together four
eggs and slowly add to the cream butter
and sugar
foreign
there you go
right now the flower and baking powder
sipping 100 grams of self-raising flour
and three teaspoons of baking powder
then add a teaspoon of ground cloves
because that really nice sort of
and a CD richness to it
there you are okay thank you
so you get that nice
right a little pinch of salt
and I'm just going to give that a nice
little mix
fold that flower in why don't you use
the Whisk when you're doing that because
I want to knock all that air out there
now into the bowl
okay
steaming the pudding in a seal container
means it Cooks slowly and keeps in all
the moisture making the sponge lovely
and light lovely
[Music]
to cover the pudding with a circle of
baking parchment take a square sheet and
fold
foreign
[Music]
Cooks
[Music]
tightly over the basin
your fingers
lovely simple
shiny side out
twist
at the end once the pudding's sealed
place a Ramekin in the pan this keeps
the Basin off the bottom so it can steam
evenly
sauce it in the bottom of it a little
sausage ready pour in hot water
pop in the pudding and steam for one and
a half hours topping it up with hot
water if it boils dry
[Music]
[Applause]
to go with the steam pudding we're
making a super simple whiskey cream
start by whisking 150 milliliters of
double cream and and whisk lovely I
always get a hard job score day
just think of those bingo Wings mum so I
mean Bingo hands smack in a minute
eyes down yes
there you are right thank you now a
little splash of whiskey
a little talk just a little drop okay
lovely and then finally a little bit
Irish cream no you're talking no we're
talking excellent
voice smells delish doesn't it we'll
stop there mum just in case we have
butter in 30 seconds time thank you
I'm not moving in the kitchen okay
that was lovely put the whiskey cream in
the fridge until you're ready to serve
well that should be ready I'm hoping of
course when the pudding has finished
steaming turn it out onto a plate does
the trick well look at that looks stuffy
doesn't it
Loosely a little bit on the sides thank
you
yeah
nice
fingers crossed this pudding is another
dish you can make in advance simply
reheat by steaming again
oops Daisy
glad you're happy
do you mind
on you go gorgeous your shoe
nice nice nice
smells amazing to follow me the pudding
eat some whiskey light at the table and
pour over
[Music]
oh